here we go
d4 will just give a moment of silence
for the fact that danny was right about
that you were right not only about that
but about the general opening which was
a catalan the general opening though i i
don't know that i was uh can fully take
credit for that i anticipated c4 which
of course for those following the match
closely could have transposed us
directly into the position we had in
game two but alas that was not meant to
be b3 was played a flexible approach
designed to kind of get things get
things messy a little bit and move order
and i want to not pause until we get to
this first moment here where c4 was met
by the move queen to c2 which robert
called for kind of a really important
little little maneuver but an important
idea robert right the pawn is pinned to
the bishop and that way white doesn't
have to take with the pawn on c4 and
compromise the queen side ponchos you
were too isolated pawn so and the
follow-up was brilliant after this right
where he says you can have my pawn i'm
playing knight d2 if you take on b3 i
take with knight the whole board opens
up and white is ahead in development
yeah and to see all the variations we
got into with bishop d6 knight f to d4
you should re-watch the live broadcast
because we did have a lot of fun and it
was instructive in real time but we will
summarize this position as saying
john was not interested in this played
knight to c6 but most importantly
followed knight c6 bobby with what
robert called one of the best moves he's
played yet in the world championship
yeah i think that jan handled the
opening surprise and we can i think
safely say knight b to d2
was a big surprise for him yep it's
pretty much an unknown idea it's
something that magnus and his team team
cooked up
but jan decided not to go for the sharp
lines where
he's under pressure he has material but
he's under pressure and he played an
excellent move b5 this eases black's
development very significantly because
he's developing with gain of tempo yep
the knight has to move from the square
and there are no there are no crushing
tactics in order here and so after the
night c moves to e5 we had knight to b4
queen b2 bishop b7 and then we also
spent a lot of time debating between the
two retreats for this night here and
ultimately applauded yawn for his
decision robert to go for the slightly
more challenging even though it seems a
slightly more awkward retreat right
because it creates tension between the
pieces and if the knight had gone to d5
instead it's a more advanced square but
it's not threading anything and could
potentially be kicked out of there so i
like to move knight to c6 it was a great
choice by young and as we saw over the
next series of moves it felt like black
was doing just fine yeah we catch up
again to the live position here and
after knight c6 knight d3 keeping the
pieces on the board bishop b6 bishop g5
rook d8 and now after bishop takes f6 we
all we all talked about this moment with
with much anticipation because there
were two choices for yon he could have
taken with the queen and we should give
credit to the challenger regardless of
the result of this game that
even though this was probably a safer
approach for him to head toward an end
game that he's in good shape to hold he
played g takes f6 the more challenging
move keeping the queens on the board
despite what that did to his kingside
pawn structure yeah gtx f6 was a brave
decision i think in hindsight if we had
seen queen takes of six we might have
seen a different result yeah it was a
safer option but to his credit and john
mentioned this in the post-game press
conference yeah that he felt like he was
the one who
had chances to play for an advantage and
that's why he played g takes up six
because clearly this is an ambitious
move yeah keeping the queens on
basically to say
yeah my king side has been weakened but
your queen on b2 is for the moment
extremely misplaced yep and i can try to
play aggressively in the center
right and after rook to c1 he did play
aggressively instead with knight to d4
although as we commented on there is a
debate that despite gtx f6 being the
more aggressive dynamic try maybe he
could have kept some pieces on the board
with something like e5 but obviously
very double-edged and risky to go for
something that has positional weaknesses
to it so we'll kind of we'll kind of let
that pass and go for the the next
critical position just just to mention
that jan did say
e5 might have been a better option okay
yeah in the presence he did mention this
move so maybe that was one of the
moments not a big moment but one of the
moments when he could have tried to
press for more yep
okay he did not he played knight to d4
the trade occurred on d4
and after queen to a2 bishop takes g2 we
we were still
while we were kind of sensing robert
that if we got an end game this knight
might be the better minor piece than the
bishop this was still a position that
black was in control over yeah it's
something that i highlighted earlier
that the light squared knight on d3
protected by a pawn the bishop can't
kick it out the bishop can't really
threaten anything that said with the
queens on the board the knight doesn't
have
access forward right and white needs to
care about the king so i think that with
the activity that black has in the
position it's definitely fine for black
but the way magnus played it it begged
questions out of beyond right that
resulted in material imbalance yeah you
start to see that right away because
after the move queen to c2 which opens
up the possibilities as you said if the
queens come off the board you already
start to like white a little bit more
and then after a5 rook to d1 you're
really preparing to get the queens off
the board with magnus's next move rook
to d2 this defends the queen it defends
the e-2 pawn really opens the idea for
this knight to move ideas like queen to
c6 for example if bishop b6 has played
we might have seen a move like this we
spent some time analyzing that
and and did that force john's hand was
this not something he wanted to go for
we saw both players asked about it and
jan said he thought rook to c8 was okay
magnus said he thought it was okay but
that it was more okay for white i i
think that this was the first huge this
decision and jan to his credit took a
very brave one yeah he imbalanced the
position
before this move it is very roughly
balanced and black i think has a number
of moves which keep it in balance i
think i heard mention of the move b4 in
the press conference
and maybe this was a very
a concrete way of trying to simplify
everything because if the bishop gets to
c3
black is doing very well and if white
takes on b4
queen takes c2 rook takes c2
or maybe bishop f2 check right it's
bishop oh bishop takes up two check in
fact
this is the first idea
and black takes on b4 and then you take
and equalizes completely maybe even more
than equalizes so this is probably one
of the only lines we actually didn't
look at in live fashion this maybe is
what black should have done
so jan decided maybe against this or
maybe he didn't spot it but rookie was a
brave decision perhaps one which in
hindsight he may regret slightly
yeah and rook to see though it was
mentioned by iphone of course he'll be
fun joins us daily if you're not tuning
in for that that's a u problem uh
but it doesn't mean that it wasn't
without great risk we we now had the
imbalance that is going to set the tone
for the rest of this coinbase rapid
recap because it was very instructive
and dynamic to see how the two rooks and
queen battled it out
but again in hindsight maybe maybe now
we agree with magnus that white was the
one with better chances and i agree with
that from the beginning as soon as we
got to this position and we just see the
next mcqueen d5 and b4a4 now we have a
set pawn structure on the queen side the
pawn on a3 is vulnerable because that's
a dark square bishop at some point
bishop b2 also the queen come into b3
but what i was advocating for was rook
c8 back to c2 and we know that later in
the game that was even more powerful for
white but the point that i was making is
that black actually can't threaten
anything and if white gets several turns
to protect a3 maybe bring that knight
forward into c5 in many of these
positions two rooks are better than the
queen because two rooks can team up on a
square and the queen is a lone piece
it's very valuable but it doesn't have
the benefit of joining forces with
another because not enough material
remaining for black and another idea you
highlighted and fabi of course was right
there with you is and we're going to see
lots of variations uh uh that display
that black's long-term weaknesses on the
king's side even if they're not an issue
in five moves and 10 moves and 15 moves
they will be an issue at some point it's
only a matter of time for white to
coordinate and defend the threats as you
said on the queen side
and that's kind of what we saw here e3
was played bishop e5 and then h4
h5 was a quick response and after king
h2
a slightly curious bishop b2 really
forced us into variations where magnus
he actually missed his first opportunity
to maybe put the game away and uh that
was actually with the move
rook to c5 followed by
rook five to c2 mission b2 was
a very serious mistake but not one which
was obvious
and i don't think
that well we heard from magnus that he
didn't see this idea after bishop to b2
yeah i think maybe ian spotted it only
after he played bishop to b2 but we we
mentioned
during the game that queen to b3 would
probably lead to a draw but it's a
difficult decision for black as well
because he allows the invasion of the
rooks knight takes e5 f takes e5 rook c7
yep
queen takes a3
rook 2 to d7 queen takes b4 rook f7 it's
very very close to being a mating attack
but after king to g6 rook to g7 king to
h6 we could not find any way for white
to continue the attack decides to go for
a perpetual but it's very understandable
that dion didn't want to go for this
where white has a safety net of a draw
and it's also difficult to be completely
sure that white doesn't have more and on
top of that the sort of winning strategy
that white had was like eight moves down
the line and included some sacrifices so
uh if we go to the rook c5
rook c2 moment that
was actually played in the game that
that was here not played yeah right rook
c
c2 is what we're looking at there are
all these variations which which we did
analyze a bishop takes a3 we talked
about knights at f4 queen takes b4 and
here after rook d7 e5 we're actually
struggling to figure it out but after
knight h5 check king g6 i believe the
move rook c6 you're giving up your
knight on h5 and you're creating a
mating net which doesn't look immediate
but the king is in trouble and look at
black's pieces the queen on b4 the
bishop one a3 not helping to save that
king and that's really hard to spot from
so many moves away so the criticism when
you have the engine evaluation with you
i know we were talking about rook c2 we
didn't see it all the way through but we
liked the dynamic chances but look at
how difficult that variation was in
magnus's immense time trouble yeah i
would say that even if you spot this if
you even if you calculate all the way
through and magnus only had three
minutes to do so
it still doesn't seem clear because
let's say you win
the
queen for one of white's rooks black
still has two connected past pawns on
the queen side even there you're not 100
sure that you can stop those pawns or
advance your pawns in time so this was
immensely difficult
but it was a big chance anyway for
magnus
yeah well said and uh
this moment
instead of the move rook to c2
was was met with rook to d1 which as you
can see again ignoring the eval bar
knowing how difficult this was
especially given the time pressure the
players had set us down a new a new time
scramble where
suddenly we were talking about maybe
this was going to be a game for the
challenger he captured the a-pawn
and and is now going to win the b pawn
by force or so we thought after the move
e5 brook c2 this was in hindsight maybe
the last the last real opportunity that
yon napomnishi had yeah bishop takes b4
we were screaming for that move and it's
begging to be played
in this position because the knight is
pinned to the rook and now black can
safely retreat the bishop try to put the
pawn in a3 and it's a much better
version of the game because instead of
taking on b4 what ended up happening is
that jan lost his e-pawn and that left
him with such a horrible pawn structure
in the resulting position that even
though the evaluation it's remained
level his task is so much harder because
all of these different end games even if
white gives away some material the pawn
trucks are so bad that a rook and a
knight can dominate against the queen
foreshadowing you are for those who
might be watching this coinbase rapid
recap on our youtube channel in terms of
what's ahead all right uh again
napolmashi did not capture on b4 he
played the surprising queen d5 and after
rook dd2 which credit to magnus he found
this move in no time and
a very difficult and subtle brook coming
forward but as you said in hindsight
kind of the only move and suddenly you
realize this bishop is trapped
unless you're going to get rid of the
knight but getting rid of the knight
requires you making a weakness with the
e4 pawn advance and suddenly everything
is changing i think we should mention e4
was probably a very big mistake okay it
was understandable that jan didn't want
to go from bishop takes b4
rook d to b2
queen takes d3 rook takes b4 where white
wins the a4 pawn and can only play for
two results
it's difficult to foresee if white can
actually make progress here but
i don't believe white ken
and if he were to go for this i don't
think his defensive task would be too
difficult because once you get here
black
really has doesn't have too many more
difficult moves left yeah black simply
has to keep an eye on the f2 pawn so
that white's rooks can't get too active
if he had done this i think that we
would likely have seen a defense by
baiyan
and it was move i believe 38. i was i
was about to say he was also in her time
he was and you're entering a point of no
return because once you get here and we
sell those trades then it's either
you're holding which doesn't initially
look like it because your pawn structure
is bad yeah the rooks can team up but it
does in fact appear that you end up
holding right so with the analysis with
some calculation he didn't have enough
time to calculate all the way through so
e4 was an understandable mistake from
yan but it put him in some tremendous
pressure and that resulted through the
rest of the game yep
e4 knight to c5 queen takes b4 and we
spent a lot of time analyzing another
maybe fun opportunity magnus had which
was the surprising rook d to c2 where
despite what it looks like at first
black's pieces are actually frozen in in
place and with without any any ability
to to move out we're going to get
variations where let's say the pawn is
protected with f5 white is able to rid
the queen side completely
of pawns and we we spent a lot of time
analyzing this endgame unlike with the
pawns on e5 and f6 which do
prevent the rooks from being ideally
coordinated is probably winning for
white again a very very difficult end
game but
back up and watch the show in real time
to see fabiano's full full breakdown uh
okay fabiano's full breakdown that
sounds like a hopefully not a full
breakdown
full breakdown magnus didn't play rook
dc2 he took on e4 uh and after queen to
b3
rook a to c2 we start to get into this
struggle here
where
okay we were definitely considering the
fact that it's now a two result position
for white but skeptical of how that was
going to happen until
one later critical moment go ahead
robert yeah i actually had mentioned
this because i was looking at the weak
pawn structure yeah and thinking that
white could give up a rook for the
bishop in apon something i mentioned
during the commentary and something you
need to keep in mind that just because
you
rook is more valuable you want to keep a
rook compared to bishop and pawn the
resulting position
leaves black no active play so by
eliminating that pawn and it was a big
mistake on jan's part coming up he
allowed that pawn to be eliminated and
then he was really in trouble yeah and
we you could already foreshadow if you
just imagine the bishop and pawn off the
board for either of these rooks you
realize just how perfect and solid white
structure is and how difficult it will
be for black to defend so uh the the
maneuvers that continued were were kind
of logical and clear until we reached
one critical moment which really in the
end may have been the critical moment
because it surprised all of us in the in
that yon
i used the word at the time during the
live show careless maybe that was harsh
it just felt a little bit
uh short-sighted in the potential that
white had here with the mistake that was
made i think this is certainly a
careless mistake and by with magnus's
last move king to g1 king g1 to h2
he showed that predicting a draw almost
i was already predicting a quick draw
because it seemed like they were both
shuffling their kings king g1 to h2
doesn't prepare anything in fact the
only idea of it is to provoke queen e4
because suddenly the king is in the line
of that bishop there's a pin on g3 pawn
so he's in a way asking why don't you
give queen e4 a shot
king h2 the king can't go anywhere so if
black were to play king g6 here king g7
a move like that
i don't believe white has anything
better than to keep shuffling
uh i i'm curious to see
well we'll never see but i'm i would
have been curious to see what magnus
would have done if beyond kept shuffling
maybe we would have seen a draw maybe
magnus had some idea in mind but it's
not very clear what that is well as you
said king h2 provokes the idea that the
g pawn is pinned and apparently that was
all that was all the provoking that yon
needed because he played queen e4 and
magnus's trap had been laid he now takes
on a3 allowing the queen to take h4 and
then with the great follow-up king g1
and you suddenly realize the pawn can't
really be taken by the bishop because
white will capture back and eventually
get out of checks and that changes
everything we're suddenly in a dynamic
where the a pawn is gone and you didn't
even have to lose your rook because of
it
we get a we're going to get a lot more
moves now where essentially
white spends the next 15 or so moves
coordinating the two brooks in the night
to be in their best possible position to
eventually make way over here against
the wheat kingside structure
the pieces maneuver
queen e4 check f3 definitely turned a
little bit of our heads right robert
well i was wondering why he was thinking
so i figured he was going to play the
move f3 and i guess he thought that he
couldn't win without making that move
because there's so many times that black
tries to move the pawn to h4 if the
king's ever on h2 you you need to leave
the h file with your king before playing
h4 as black but that was the problem
that he foresaw so he ends up playing f3
and that gave him more time to maneuver
around and eventually it led him into a
very promising position f3 was followed
by f4 and we suddenly saw another reason
why f3 was playable because surprisingly
you don't even have to keep the pawn
there once you dislodge the bishop these
pawns can't be protected which means the
fortress is uh is starting to show some
holes
again white's pieces coordinate
incredibly well over the over the coming
series of moves we we should highlight
that f5 was the move we were talking
about as an eventual requirement as
risky as it was to put pawns on these
weak squares because you have to prevent
white from making progress here
yeah all of these moves that magnus made
yeah they don't differ so much from
other moves in terms of evaluation
but the thing that he did which was
amazing was that he kept the position
tense and full of life he didn't allow
it to simplify for a long time until
they were both low on time right and he
he realized that although the evaluation
or the the
objective evaluation is probably close
to equal or simply equal
with perfect play black is the one who
has to make the more difficult decisions
here right and already here we were
starting to see
even even two moves before so we were
starting to see that black was getting
in trouble with this f5 pawn which is
which is very difficult to defend long
term because the bishop can't ever
defend it and it can be attacked by two
rooks but only defended by one queen
well and as soon as white had the
opportunity the pawns it did start to
fall now yawn to his credit was
tenacious and and would not go away
queen to d3 now forces an even more more
forcing idea which if you i would love
to say if you wanted to pause the video
and see that the the transition magnus
made it's it's certainly an educational
one not to mirror yourself for the type
of advantage you have but just mirror
yourself to the idea of winning and
robert he sacrificed on f7 a tactic you
saw coming and and uh with this you win
a a bishop and pawn for the rook but
really put white in a position where
there was there was no longer doubt that
white was the only one who could win and
that it would be very difficult for
black to hold yeah there was a practical
problem earlier with the pawn e3 yeah
bishop and the queen were lined up at
that point the white rooks could not
actually defend because the looseness of
the other rook so here he goes for this
he says i have a rook a knight in two
pawns and i can play this game out i'll
make a pawn move when i have to but he
was in no rush and magnus showed great
technique in rerouting his pieces keep
asking yon questions like where's your
queen gonna go what's the best square
can you stop my pawn from going to e4 is
that devastating yan actually was
playing very well here and it was only
much later in the game after tons and
tons of shuffling that jan eventually
made an error but that's because he was
exhausted it was nearing midnight in
dubai and magnus was relentless in the
pressure he put on yeah one of the
educational things uh speaking of a
relentless approach by magnus is how the
knight maneuvered consistently putting
itself in a spot both of you highlighted
a couple times that your your former
childhood coach talks about the knights
being knight being such a key defender
to the king how a knight can dominate a
queen in close proximity that's a theme
that not only paid dividends here but
ultimately helped him convert on the
advantage at the end of the game we see
keeping the knight close to the king
allows you to have security and allows
you to maneuver and eventually allowed
magnus to push his advantage as soon as
he could with these pawns getting
rolling up the board this was move 110
and as soon as he played it we knew that
we weren't going to have a repetition a
three-fold repetition we wouldn't have a
15-move draw and that we would more than
likely be making history today with the
longest ever world chess championship
game in history uh which of course was
the previous record of 124 moves between
courtney and karpuff in 1978 but this
game was on pace to break that and uh
break that it did i think that this
whole end game was magnus magnus at his
best yeah even though it looked like he
was moving in circles for a long time
he
always kept control of the position
and he always slowly made progress he
knew that he had time black has no
counter play so he played with absolute
patience
and with every move we felt white is
making progress even though the
objective evaluation
in this position and in most of these
positions was a draw it felt harder and
harder for yon to
to keep defending it until at some point
it was just too difficult to uh to
handle
we're going to get to that point here in
just a second because as fabiano uh and
hester both sang it just it was a
difficult battle and in fact
it was right here this was the moment
and i'll let you take it away robin and
explain why the table base says black
should draw this but why that is a
completely unfair standard to hold any
human too yeah it's pretty hard to hold
them queenie six against jan because
you're putting the rook in a pin and
you're bringing the queen to a place
where it can deliver some more checks
the problem is knights are amazing at
defending kings against queens because
they cover so many important squares
while blocking the file that the queen
is on so queen c2 or queen b1 those were
necessary choices for janus but the only
two moves that objectively hold the game
because the knight needs to remain
protecting the rook of course but also
it also leaves many checks open so if
the king tries to run up the board too
quickly there are more checks um to go
you can pin the knight of course like
this and so white isn't able just run
forward and in the game after queen e6
we saw a very quick conclusion here
because up goes the white king you get
one more check on h6 and look at the
knight on h5 even if you're a rook or
not an f5 the knight covers f4 it covers
f6 and it blocks the check on the file
that it's on which means that the queen
is just parried by that one knight and
then we saw a really beautiful move next
where
magnus was able to push his e-pawn
because the rook on f5 not attacked
knight g7 check is a winning fork and
after e6 was played the rest as they say
was history yep young played a couple
more moves with queen g6 and then rook
f7 again showing the line that queen e6
does not work because this end game
although it makes black feel a little
better maybe but we don't they don't
they don't play for almosties and
feeling good this is still a lost end
game if you know your king and pawn
endings white goes on to win easily and
so with that not being an option for the
russian he
well he he ran the king away or tried to
but after f5
queen g1 and knight g7 we did indeed
finally have
a resignation
with again just a brilliant display
there of how pieces can outplay the
queen together how perseverance and and
uh pushing hard especially the practical
nature of using the clock as a weapon
objectively this game was a draw for
many many moves yet it feels in
hindsight that the result for magnus was
never in doubt
yeah this was a game that was marred at
the start by some serious errors
to be to be fair very understandable
errors because it was such a complicated
position and they were low on time
but uh the end of the game or the end of
the game was quite long the last
50 moves or so was just absolutely
brilliant technique from magnus
very tenacious defense as well
but
magnus didn't
never let up on the pressure and when
you never let up on the pressure at some
point your opponent cracks and that's
exactly what happened
in case you didn't see our partners at
coinbase are sponsoring chess.com
coverage of the 2021 feed a world
championship and boy are we thankful
whether you're an experienced trader
been doing this for years or just
thinking about making your first crypto
purchase coinbase is the place to go
visit coinbase.com chess and get five
dollars in free bitcoin when you sign up
and verify your account today
[Music]
you